so the first kind is the idea of deep
time humility this is to recognize that
humankind
that has only been around for a couple
of hundred thousand years is just an
eye blink in the cosmic story
in fact deep time is quite a new idea it
only really emerged in the late 18th
century
when geologists started discovering the
evidence that the earth was far
older than the 6 000 years that the
bible was telling western culture
but was in fact hundreds of thousands
millions maybe billions of years
old and that we were just a tiny moment
in this
long history of the planet and the
universe itself
but it can be quite difficult to really
grasp
that huge temporal scale and the writer
john mcphee who invented the term deep
time
came up with a beautiful metaphor to try
and help us grasp
its meaning he said consider the earth's
history
as the old measure of the english yard
the distance from the king's nose
to the tip of his outstretched hand one
stroke of a nail file
on his middle finger
erases human history
that's short we've only been around for
that very eye blink
but let's remember too that deep time
doesn't just go
far into the past it goes long into the
future
in six billion years any creatures that
will be around to see
al sun die will be as different from us
as we are from the first
single celled bacteria
so this is what this humility of deep
time is all about
recognizing there's so much time before
us so much time to come
and who are we to break the great chain
of life
without ecological destruction and
dangerous technologies
what kind of arrogance is that
that's what i get out of deep time and
it helps me think to myself okay
let me try and get in touch with that
longer sense of time that
ecological choreography of the planet
the long cycles
that we've lost touch with i'm not
saying this is easy
but we can make the effort you know i
was recently
on summer vacation with my children and
we went to a beach on the south coast of
england
and in our hands we held
belamites a fossil squid-like creature
that was 195 million years
old no human being had ever set its eyes
on this fossil that we'd hunted hours to
find
but that gave us a sense of the wonder
of deep time
or you can go and visit your local
ancient tree
probably within some miles or a short
bicycle ride from where you live
you there might be a tree that's over a
thousand years old maybe it's a
californian bristlecone pine which is
four thousand years old
not far from me there's a yew tree which
is maybe 1200 years old
and you can sit underneath it and follow
the advice of the vietnamese
monk titna han who said don't just do
something
sit there in other words don't take a
selfie of yourself but
try and absorb that sense of deep time